imágenes satelitales muestran la
destrucción en la fábrica de acero de
azov tal esta zona de la ciudad de
mariupol ha sido objeto de un asedio
ruso durante semanas varios centenares
de soldados y civiles ucranianos se han
refugiado en túneles bajo la planta ante
el avance de las fuerzas de vladimir
putin el sábado el batallón a soft que
defiende el lugar afirmó que se había
mantenido un alto el fuego pre acordado
a partir de las 7 40 de la noche hemos
trasladado a 20 civiles rescatados de
los escombros hacia el lugar acordado se
trata de mujeres y niños y esperamos que
estas personas vayan en la dirección
pactada es decir a la ciudad de sap
orilla territorio controlado por ucrania
el batallón de asof conocido por tener
vínculos con la extrema derecha dijo que
había estado limpiando los escombros por
los bombardeos nocturnos de rusia para
rescatar a los civiles atrapados sin
embargo las fuerzas rusas acusan a los
soldados ucranianos de mantener a los
civiles como rehenes en la planta en
kiev los familiares de los combatientes
encerrados en la acería se manifestaron
el sábado pidiendo la evacuación de sus
seres queridos
mi padre mi marido o su hermano el
marido de mi hermana está en el mariupol
son del batallón asof ahora están en las
ob sales están bloqueados allí sé que se
les está acabando la comida no tienen
ninguna medicina están heridos
volodymyr se lens que advirtió que la
muerte de las tropas defensoras de
mariupol supondría el fin de las
conversaciones de paz